none of you have a chance of succeeding
in the biggest opportunity you have
which is building your own brand and
leveraging that against your Ambitions
if you don't have the macro pieces in
place the macro pieces in place are
strictly mindset there's no chance
you're going to work hard enough produce
good enough content or anything else
that's required to achieve what you want
unless you're in a good place it's no
different than building a home the
things you all sell it doesn't matter
how well you decorate the living room or
how nice the color of the paint is in
the master bedroom if you do not have
steel and concrete that holds up the
building